but don't go on stage and have a ho-hum
set people get up there and they're just
like so uh bro this is your job and
these [__] people will go up three
years into comedy just like and so I was
playing uh uh
an app game and what's the deal with
[__]
Bejeweled and and you're like this
it's my Friday night I make [__]
chairs at all you know what I'm saying
kinda
oh
Runk
[Music]
hello hello
it works though super well
cool
yep so I can breathe how do you
so are you gonna get the surgery I mean
eventually I'm pretty sure I'll have to
but
that works for now that's amazing yeah
wow how's your nose though after all
that stuff
um it's really dry so whenever it's
really dry it um
it still makes it so it's clock clogged
because I can't get like the there's
like this like layer of like I guess
dried mucus around
my nostril so the construction is better
but
is this the show yeah sure we're talking
about my nose surgery great show well
whatever we'll do a clip up front
that'll be banging you know as long
we'll be like here it comes and then
we'll start talking about the nose well
everybody knows we have bad noses you
know internal noses but the breathing is
better for you you're saying yeah except
for when it's dry when I'm dry a lot so
it's like inflamed or it closes off yeah
it sucks so I don't know I don't know if
it was worth it I guess it was yeah but
they also said with that kind of stuff
it takes when I had my sinus corrective
surgery they were like
it'll start to feel better soon but it
won't be fully better in until three
years from now three yeah dude oh oh I
heard six months or something wow that's
good obviously different things right
right true yeah but we're the same
doctors oh yeah we did right yep
um so I don't ever like when music is on
there I said it but you I don't ever
like when it's on ever but but is that
the same thing as not liking music or
what I understand why music is good so I
you know
but you'll randomly like a song I will
yeah I will like what is the song you do
like you're a rich girl and you know you
don't come and they know you're gonna
panel anyway you're a rich girl and you
know you don't come
well we gotta bleep that out you know
uh but wait what you like that song Or
that was just it's nice okay well what
else do you like adult adult adult
education
so why do you like hip-hop then you like
hip you like show drop music yeah yeah
well I know I like yeah I like Tupac
yeah you don't like rap music I like
hip-hop but I don't like the new stuff
really I like Tech Nine yeah he's new
right well he's I mean at this time at
this point he's like 50 but yeah oh
really I mean I don't know if he's 50
but yeah he's older I mean I'm not like
the 21 year old like Lil Durk kind of
stuff I don't I can appreciate it though
like I like um that song with little
Dirk is good but only because of uh
what's his name the other guy the big
big Jake Hall
so yeah so uh Jake hole who's that
rapper just went to uh jail for shooting
all of them Megan thee stallion's feet
oh oh how long is he gonna be in jail
for 10 years 10 years
isn't that crazy here's here's what's up
with me and I'm I've I've known this for
a while now but I really it really sort
of sunk in even further when I read
about that I don't want anybody to go to
jail
almost ever you have to actually kill
someone
or commit like a really violent
otherwise violent crime uh or
I mean there are Financial crimes I
guess but even though I'm like oh damn
talk about years in jail a lot of time
the financial crime is just like I just
got caught up you know you're like oh
like you know what yeah I do know he I
do know exactly what he did he shot her
foot but even then right exactly like
Joe Pesci yeah he was he was actually
saying dance dance dance and shot her
feet at her feet and like bullet
shrapnel got lodged in her feet and
everything and at first she actually
lied to the cops because she didn't want
him to get in trouble and then
eventually she obviously told the truth
and she ended up having to take the
stand she says it like ruined her life
which I totally understand really it's
double traumatic you got to actually
have that experience and then you gotta
actually go through all the courtroom
procedures yeah to make the guy go to
jail you know what I don't get is if
somebody he has no chance at parole
which is the craziest part
some violation he committed during the
trial or something like that there's no
there's some like rule that he broke
that says he if he's found guilty is no
chance of pearl so he's going to be in
jail for 10 years no matter what for
being Joe Pesci
and Joe Pesci got off Scotland because
she never went to jail so hold on so
well his head was in a vice right wasn't
that him he got killed well no he put a
guy's head in advice and at the end of
that movie he got beat with aluminum
baseball bats kicked into a hole and at
the when we saw that movie in the
theater with Mom and Dad there was a
couple behind us that kept oh wait hold
on how old were you when that movie came
out yeah I was either 11 or 12. what it
was that young it was 1995 when Casino
came out okay so Casino comes out I was
15. I was 14. we saw
my dad was really excited because well
he's excited anyway love Score says he
but the book had the Nicholas palegi
book that it's based on yeah my dad was
like obsessed with this movie Casino
double time so he was excited to see the
movie we all went to see with Robert De
Niro Joe Pesci opening weekend yeah if
you don't know Casino we'll just get the
head check a lot of people don't know
but that's true but all you guys get the
head checked if you don't think
uh so we're in the theater I'm totally
unaware of this the entire time but
apparently threw up in this course of
the movie
huh sorry did you open this for me go
ahead it doesn't matter sorry I'm sorry
uh throughout the course of the movie uh
unbeknownst to me I don't know if you
heard it as well but anyway this this uh
yeah I did not know during the couple
this like waspy
older white bread older couple but not
not senior citizens but older like in
their 60s maybe maybe maybe yeah uh was
like chirping the whole time the woman
especially was like oh I can't believe
this man would take his family to see
this movie oh it's so pretty wild that's
so violent and I can't believe that it
was parents of the year that's what they
were saying parents of the Year about my
mom and dad that at the end that's what
they said after the movie okay so then
at the end of the movie The Credits come
up and
apparently inspired by what he had just
seen my dad who was a very mild-mannered
very even killed I mean I've seen him
get mad less than five times uh and this
was one of those times and but to me I
didn't know what was going on so all of
a sudden to my eye he's just
barking at this
couple that are things that he said were
unbelievable yeah he was like I mean why
you know just Joe Pesci stuff but he was
basically being Joe pastry yeah yeah the
Joe Patrick characters
he'd come back here and fight me you
[__] fat pig I was like oh
just calling somebody a fat pig like
what happened I didn't want to say it
but you did so okay well I mean he
regrets it you know what I mean but he's
also 76 now so you can't really yeah I
mean this was this was many many years
ago and he was just it triggered him for
real he was like full on triggered that
he was being called a bad parent yeah
for taking his kids to see Casino which
I don't care if my dad took me I was
gonna see Casino in the theaters under
summer as an 11 year old I was gonna go
figure out a way to see that really yeah
dude yeah and and then after what's that
trench coat with somebody else yeah two
of us yeah and then after that my dad
made us eat uh Brushwood and Mortadella
so it was really crazy how Italian he
was yeah eat it eat it eat it I put your
head in the vice and he had a wife beat
her on yeah and uh not for nothing but
eat the whole thing yeah yeah and um and
he was crying about his own mother
because that's what all tough guy
Italians do yeah yeah so uh no but that
did happen and it was pretty [__]
insane it was crazy it was crazy yeah
and and we're like Dad what the [__] and
the guy was like and I was like I'm
literally pushing his wife I did not
hear the couple say anything during the
movie did you not one word
not one word
but if that made it up just because you
wanted to be like Joe pescia I mean yeah
I was crazy it was truly crazy
especially because it's so so out of
character for him what's so yeah what's
so annoying is that they those people
said anything behind why would they say
something I mean I will say it is pretty
[__] crazy to bring an 11 year old to
casino it's very weirdly violent but
here's the thing
I was a particular 11 year old I wasn't
just somewhere no no already seen Good
Fellas I know I already knew I wanted to
make movies when I grew up like it was
like yeah it was a thing I deeply cared
about it was a it was a specific unique
situation I would never ever let Calvin
see casino at 11 years old oh I'm gonna
show it to him at 11 years old I mean I
just I I'm not saying that that's like
obviously it's fine you you know
even I was 14 yeah and I was like oh God
the end is crazy brutal dude the bad bad
thing but you gotta have it that ending
it's been such a terrible guy the whole
movie it actually is a good lesson for
an 11 year old yeah but you can get that
lesson in a [__] children's book you
don't have to be a violent criminal or
else you will have a violent comeuppance
come upon you I guess that yeah wait is
the book really good I never read the
book what based on yeah how have you
never read the book you've seen the
movie [__] 100 million times it's not
really it's the book is a true story
yeah the movie is very Loosely right of
course yeah true story of it didn't
really matter to me no I understand but
you still you love that movie so much
you'd want to see what it was based on I
would think uh I know the basic bones of
the actual story I know but that I'm
just saying I'm shocked you haven't read
the book okay we'll get off my backup no
that's what I'm just saying you fat pig
I'm reading uh
1984. for the second time nice and I am
I for the first time I didn't get the
whole way through I only read like 100
pages and now I'm on the second time
reading you're actually reading it I'm
on page 36 or something it's funny how
people talk about 1984 so much and
anytime well obviously
anyone reads yeah it's I think people
are probably surprised especially for
the first time it's really not
straightforward and easy to understand
no it's not but it is also very and I
know this is the thing that people say
it is very weird How It Was Written in
1945 yeah and it's still exactly kind of
what's Happening Now well I think it's
because that's what happens every time
uh any kind of totalitarian regime gains
a foothold or not even totalitarian
regime an oppressive majority or an
oppressive I understand but the way that
guy was able to tap into that and know
that at whatever age he was when he
wrote that is is Bonkers it's so smart
crazy time 90 45 was World War II I know
it just ended Germany a lot of places
totalitarianism you know totalitarianism
that's a
totalitarian did you ever read uh animal
you read animal farm right no uh maybe
what was it the same thing but for kids
it's about the totalitarian that grows
they they kicked the farmer out of the
and then all the animals take over and
they're gonna be like great Communists
and we're gonna share everything and
everything's gonna be even now finally
for the animals and then like the bad
animals take over and take all the Grain
and food and make all the Lesser weaker
animals do uh hard work it sounds so
boring everyone read that in school man
oh yeah they don't say it's about
so drunk but it is I don't know it's
specifically in that that one is
specifically about about hotelenarianism
communism oh okay so it's not about
italianarianism well no communism
usually in practice different a form of
totalitarianism I know that so Hitler is
a
the Nazi well so it's not why it's one
of the reasons that he
if there wasn't that stuff it wouldn't
be this stuff is an example of the
excesses of the right right and Stalin
and Lenin are examples of the excesses
of the left as is Mao and yeah and it's
all good and Stalin is
dead so sure is we know where that gets
you but uh there's a there's a four-hour
movie called State funeral with no
dialogue no plot it's just footage of
different parts of Russia morning Stalin
when he died they had all these
ceremonies and all these like thousands
of people would come out and just be
it's like it's like those videos of when
uh is it on Kim Jong-il died is it on
Hulu no it's on mubi
yeah what's that movie is like the
higher end it's like not quite Criterion
level but it's a really great story whoa
I didn't even know about mubi yeah it's
got really great stuff dude m-u-b-i it's
one of the better streaming sites that's
like to be but movie what movie actually
was first oh wow 2b's a [__] that sucks
but 2B is great too
guys the gutter but everything I love to
be there's nothing not on 2B anything
that has ever been made is on to be our
home videos are in 2B
[Laughter]
I love Toby lost her mind so uh and then
I saw last night I saw a movie called
men men oh I saw that and
dude I saw that what's up with that
movie I don't know because I fell asleep
in it
all right the rudest thing you can say
about a movie is you fell asleep and you
didn't even ask the people you were with
what happened because you were so bored
the whole time
it's definitely a movie to fall asleep
too we'll talk about it more on Lifeline
luxury congratulations we're gonna do
Lifeline luxury later but uh yeah calls
to get to Sundays are for Lifeline go
sign up for patreon for a patreon uh
patreon.com Lifeline luxury there's a
new episode out right now uh you can
catch me on tour I'm gonna be in
Charlotte uh uh and uh Knoxville and
also Little Rock Arkansas
and Nashville Calgary Edmonton Ottawa
anyway a bunch of places in Canada
Pittsburgh I'm gonna be in uh Cleveland
I'm gonna be Montreal yeah I mean you
know Detroit uh chrisley.com uh for
tickets and then if you have a question
click the link in the description below
for a Lifeline or go to watch
lifeline.com or leave us a message on
the hotline it's below and uh send us a
video describing a situation with a
weirdo in your life that would be good
if you want a one-on-one advice session
with Matt Matt does those you go to
mattelia.com and you can get the
lifeline merch absolutely beautiful
merch actually absolutely luxury
beautiful put together
absolutely amazing fabric
lifelinemerch.com we've got purple we've
got Carnation purple we have black we
have Crow black crow we have Carnation
purple we have beige
goth chicken black yeah so anyway uh
thank you thank you thank you thank you
very much and like like And subscribe so
that's it
receiving Applause the way you said that
thank you thank you so all right let's
do it let's get into our first uh thing
here uh our first video uh and let's see
what's up
what's up Matt what's up what's up
actually that's sweaters my hoodie's so
cool.com
I just wanted to
um comment on
um the crank of Mattel episode you guys
opened up a memory for me that I
completely forgot that's what we do I
also saw the Pablos Francisco stand up
special because anytime when I would
hear the word Irvine I would say Irvine
and I never knew why I said it like that
you guys put that back spoiled brats in
Irvine head now so I'm very grateful for
that oh yeah but I also wanted to ask
what are some of you guys's Inspirations
who who's the people who immediately get
so excited and how important are
Inspirations to you guys today what a
good question
um uh yeah so
love Lifeline life rips and it's super
good
and super good thank you very much well
always standing he's leaving folks
he has Speedos on what's Happening
I got a trunk on me right
oh so I look at all the inspirational
videos online and about working out who
inspires you man not like
Lee Haney
no come on who inspires you uh
oh God who inspires me it's it well it's
it's there's two types of inspiration
there's the kind where you look at and
you want to emulate and there's the kind
that you look at like my son my son's
like I I see them do things and I that
inspires me to be okay yeah more and
better so I would say my big one is my
family and my sons
um and and you know my
like you guys like my not my my family
of origin and stuff but like
um yeah I mean that inspires me for sure
yeah and then and then I and then and
then the other stuff is like my mommy
inspires me too I love my mommy but then
the other stuff is
like good people inspire me like when I
sit down and I have a lunch with
somebody and I find what that they're
living the life they want to live
um like I have friends that are like
this uh and then I think wow that's good
I want to I guess I want to live like
that like a lot of mine have come from
you know when I was in rehab or recovery
but then also
um then then there's also like comedians
that inspire me that when I see them do
it doesn't have to be a big name or
anything or even my favorite comedian
but when I see someone doing new stuff
that's kind of working it's
inspirational and I'm like okay I could
do that I want to do that and then I and
then I try and do that got it but but no
like
figures that are enduringly
inspirational to me
yeah I I always think of Tupac I always
think of Tupac and how he was just so
himself and didn't give a [__] and then
I often think about what the [__] would
a guy like that be like that now he'd
probably be very much the same I know
but how would he be dealing with like
what how would what would the reaction
be you know like like I'm in a in a
situation where I get to say whatever I
want because of my profession and I've
already you know I'm not doing Hollywood
so I can just like I put out an
Instagram video today where I was making
a joke that was about racism and I could
I didn't have to not post it because I
don't have to worry about losing a
[__] brand you know deal because
Tupac probably would have lost a few yo
yo yeah his time uh in this climate at
least but he also would not give a [__]
yeah I mean honestly sometimes the
people who are inspirational to me are
people who are considered like
not like not like good in the media you
know what I mean because they they try
as you mean yeah yeah yeah like like a
lot of a lot of [__] because they
stand up for whatever yeah exactly like
because they just don't like the the
left just kind of doesn't you know but
um yeah it's it's I don't know I don't
know specifically honestly I don't know
um yeah I mean Inspirations I think
there are ones that I like when I was a
kid I wanted to like be when I grew up
like people like John cassavetes yeah
he's very inspiring yeah honestly it's
very inspiring when I later in life when
I sort of discover when I started
reading more I didn't read a lot when I
was like even before I was like 20 even
in college I didn't really read that
much that all came like right after
college I started doing that but once I
started getting that kind of stuff like
certain writers certain thinkers like
Sam Harris like when I was I guess yeah
when I was in college and Sam was like
in his 20s still I was extremely
inspired by him and his whole like the
new atheists they were called like it
was him you were listening to Sam Harris
when you were in your when you're in
college not listening he didn't have a
podcast obviously but like he he was he
was a writer he wrote a book called the
end of faith that while he was in uh I
think in his master's degree he wrote
the end of faith and it became such a
big thing that he dropped out of school
and became like a public figure but I
think one of the most the most
inspirational people in like this
climate
and it kind of touches on what you're
saying people who kind of don't bend to
any sort of crowd or Trend or whatever
of the day is Christopher hitches I find
Christopher Hitchens to be one of the
most inspiring figures yeah could not
even I actually disagree with him on a
lot of stuff yeah yeah yeah that I guess
that's what I mean it's like a matter
because the way he is about his opinions
they're fully thought through he fully
thinks them in his zero percent afraid
to speak about any of them and you know
it's not that I like people who speak
their mind and are super opinionated I
like that when they're they have reasons
to believe those things and can explain
those things it's like yeah sure
everybody's entitled to their opinion
but I don't give a [__] about yours if
there's no basis for thinking it and
it's flimsy and it falls apart but
Hitchens dude his mind was just like
utterly encyclopedic in fact if you
watch him speak mid debate it's just
like where's he even storing this stuff
and he's often drunk when he does it
he's just like a complete
absolute genius and a true one of a kind
and those are things that I've he died
yeah he died yeah he did and he was one
of those new atheists and when he was
dying he was very sick he had the chemo
he had no hair people would always ask
him like what do you think about what
happens when you die zero percent change
zero percent of it was he like well I
found God and this and that maybe
opening up maybe nah he thinks what he
[__] thinks sick or not dying or not
here or not here it doesn't matter he
just goes like this he goes
food and last words
women aren't funny
actually actually I do think he had a
big you got to do a lot one of the
things he said thing about how he said
women aren't funny yet but he wrote a
whole article about it I mean it's so
funny dude I don't even know what he
meant to be funny but he was just like
they don't need to be I don't yeah that
was the thing I don't know why why women
aren't fun right that's the article
right
call it something else you know such a
[__] starter man
so dead and it was Vanity Fair it makes
so it's so funny when it got it's a it's
so funny when a guy talks like that and
is able to it's why I like some like
Chris Rock like
to make sense of something like that it
doesn't mean you're right but it to make
it make sense the way you're breaking it
down is [__] utterly hilarious like
for him to say well they don't need to
be it's so it's actually a good point
women don't need to be funny I think his
argument is that men need to be funny to
be able to participate in the gene pool
in the exciting yes right and women and
women don't don't need that attribute
because men will like them anyway of
course right okay but that's and that's
fair to say but what about Wendy
leaveman dude no no no well they're
women
is what about Wendy Lee no I know I know
she's the funniest she is the funniest
oh you think so too yeah she's so funny
dude I was at the airport with her once
and I was just like I can't believe that
Wendy Lehman is she's so funny you know
Judy tenuta do you know her yeah a
little before Wendy Liebman she's just
like a Sandra Bernhardt is also
hilarious yeah not that obviously women
are funny but like that is a hilarious
article yeah some women are funny I mean
you know you can't just say also yeah
well you can't say men are funny either
right the least funny people I know are
certainly men you know why why because
they think they're funny dude but they
are funny but well not everybody they
don't mean to be funny no but what I'm
saying is obviously I'm not taking the
place of like well sore men I'm just
saying the yeah people who are the least
funny are to me men who think they're
funny but aren't there's nothing worse
oh it's bad being around a guy who like
is super confident women are like that
too it's so equally annoying when a
woman does it sure I know less women
okay right because you're sexist and you
don't hang out with yeah exactly yeah I
refuse to hang out
um my whole thing is when women are like
they turn 30 when hot women turn 30 and
they decide to do stand-up that to me is
just like it's so glaringly obvious that
you're that like less dudes are looking
at you now that now you're like [__]
roping them into having to look at you I
never thought about it like that the way
I thought about that was you did you're
30 and hot and you're starting stand up
now you're terrible what I thought about
that what I've always thought about that
well not about specifically getting into
stand-up comedy but I've like I've had
actually several girlfriends now who
and I've always dated women my age and
never really been a young woman so many
of them have been either approaching 30
or yes after 30 and uh they were many of
them were actresses and that was around
the time they started to be like well I
want to do funny stuff yeah but I think
though in my mind with them my feeling
was always they know that their looks
aren't going to last forever yeah and
maybe they're not the best actors in the
world so they need like other options
that's the way I was yeah that's a nice
way to think of it
well these were people I was intimately
involved with so I was going to give
right the most generous possible reason
but however Hollywood is about broken
souls and these people are most of the
time like well guys aren't paying
attention to me anymore let's [__]
hijack a comedy show because I could get
on because I'm hot but don't you think
it's more about survival of their career
or their livelihood I don't you think
it's just like a an ego thing yes I do I
mean it I do because people aren't that
deep especially women in Hollywood it
doesn't take deep the depth to be uh
about your own survivors survival but
they're just like I need people to look
at me I think it's that simple they're
just like ah I'm gonna be funny
dude if nobody ever told you you were
funny
besides your friends and besides a guy
that wants to [__] you every now and
then you're not funny don't do stand up
and and then like so many like also so
many female comedians will be like oh uh
we don't get the same opportunities like
horse [__] you can jump on any lineup
it's full of [__] people that are
just like oh yeah chicks let's have them
on that's ridiculous there's that funny
Bill Burr thing where uh he's asked
about something like that I can't
remember oh yeah yeah
he's like he's just like stop he's like
just be funny it's the truth dude go up
and murder if you can murder you're
great well that's the thing about it no
more female doesn't matter and there are
females that [__] murder yes and
there are men that murder yeah just do
that talk about crime talk about crime
but don't go on stage and have a ho-hum
set and a Friday night because it
happens all the time dude it happens all
the time [__] people get up there and
they're just like so uh bro this is your
job [__] out there make
furniture and you [__] sit in a chair
for years and these [__] people will
go up three years into comedy just like
and so I was playing uh uh an app game
and what's the deal with [__]
Bejeweled and and you're like this
it's my Friday night I make [__]
chairs [__] you know what I'm saying
kinda mostly it's just so whack dude why
you laughing so much
I'm what
gonna kick on one his ass dude die just
[__] you know why I'm asking him why
he's laughing so hard because I want to
know because I'm invested in what he
thinks is funny because he's an audience
that I want my audience to think I'm as
funny as possible because I obsess about
it because I'm Bonkers good at stand up
because it's all I ever want to do and I
didn't turn 32 and then decide to get on
stage because people stop looking at me
because now I got some wrinkles I go on
stage because I
I obliterate and dude people who talk
[__] can't follow me
bro are you blocked if you're talking
[__] you must be blocked cause you can't
follow me dude
sounds kind of seems like you're
actually talking to me you know
bro I buy a chair I swear things
what the [__] chair thing dude dude I
buy a chair I sit in it for years dude
if it breaks I don't go back so what are
you doing on stage three years in
talking about Bejeweled
okay uh speaking of Inspirations uh
yeah good video you know we got that
covered you know
we got that covered all right who's next
Candy Crush was the thing I couldn't the
jeweled was the worst
closet your girlfriend I'm being held
hostage right now
I don't know who to call so I'm single
Lifeline video in please come help me
uh
hey Matt and Chris I'm at work right now
so I have to be brief but I'm wondering
how y'all feel about your girlfriend
popping your pimples
anywhere close to her but sometimes it
seems like if I you know if I'm anywhere
around her she's dialed in and she goes
to me and starts popping pimples on my
body and my face and it hurts first of
all so gross how do you all feel about
that problems bro my frips cleaners
no no no this guy yeah I know about the
uncle Uncle Sam dude dude I yesterday
Uncle bald sound talked about this
yesterday I talked about this with
Kristen did I did she do it
every single girlfriend has ever done it
dude me too except for one
one
never has once done it and you know what
she's by far the best one okay well not
because of that but I'm just maybe maybe
because it could be but what I'm saying
is
it's unreal how much they want to do it
what is that I don't know women would
ever want to do that yeah some yeah hey
a woman please send us a video yeah yeah
and tell us why you want to do that yeah
because I I've told Kristen and here's
the thing I've told Kristen she'll be
like oh let me get it I say please don't
I don't like when you do it I let just
leave it or I'm gonna you don't like it
no no it hurts when she does it when I
do it it doesn't because I know what
kind of pain is happening I kind of
always liked it but I I got it but I
like a little bit of pain sometimes all
right so
that's when I do it too though no it
hurts when I do it too you know you can
at least control the level
keeper
um so but and then she I was like come
on and I asked her I said yo I very
seriously I don't want you to do this
anymore you broke it down really you
were like I don't know and I was like
yeah she's like okay guess what she
still did it so great so she did it
yesterday so I and I said no don't you
do what she said okay I won't do it but
dude this is the other thing dude I'll
say to her hey
why do all chicks want to do this it
should be like don't say that I'm not
like that or whatever the [__] this is
another thing that that women will do
and you're like oh dude so now I don't
even get to you're gonna [__] hurt my
and while I'm and I don't get to say the
thing that's by the way true wait so
what is her what is her every every
woman I've ever been with likes to do
that I guess what is she and every woman
I've ever been with when I say why do
[__] chicks all like to do this they
say oh I'm like oh chicks I'm not like
that oh really
damn hey you're on a sitcom huh in life
hey your life is a sitcom hey
yeah
okay dude it's it's unbelievable I don't
know what it is about that that like yes
but this the truth is sir yes yes
there's something going on with that no
no it's so weird dude it must be uh
taking care of grooming I mean you know
like that like moms for sure like to
groom their kids when they come out
maybe it's a version of that also also
there's like yeah I mean for sure it's
like an eternally baked into human
because Kristen is always like with the
hair on Calvin and William and [__] and
you're like it's fine also skin in
general is it women are much more well
for sure active and and interested in
keeping their skin healthy so it makes
sense that they would extend that to
their yeah boyfriends or husbands or
whatever you know yeah but still it is
it is odd it is odd yeah
yeah actually now that I'm thinking
about there were a couple specifically
that you don't think about this obsessed
with it's so weird man doing it yeah and
it wasn't just a couple it was all of
them but anyway so no all of them would
do it yeah two in particular were like
like obsessed with like
pulled down your shirt like a shirt God
there's more than two but yeah pull down
your pants
two of them we would go out on the
street and be like let's find guys to
bomb purples on
oh that guy looks good sir take off your
shirt what excuse me what
yeah yeah dude
but that [__] okay yeah okay yeah we
don't know yeah tell her no dude so make
a boundary
ah they don't respect them though what
do you want
next one who's next
all right guys I am reaching out because
I want advice to reach out to the next
or not uh in a relationship
two years ago and we were together for
13 months it was very toxic mental
emotional physical everywhere okay
um but there was a lot of substance
abuse in that so take that into account
but anywho I've been single for almost
two years and I've been dating I've been
putting myself out there I go to therapy
I'm very open to everything but I still
think about him frequently and I'm still
missing him even though I know he's not
a great person so my advice is that I
need is should I reach out to him
just to see what he says like we're like
closure or help me or should I reach out
to other than my therapist
who else should I reach out to I guess
or should I or not thank you love you
guys bye thank you for the question yeah
100 absolutely no I think uh here's the
thing are you are you she's mentioned
closure and that surprised me I thought
she was saying should I reach out and
get to get back that is what I thought
you said but she said should I reach out
and then she said something about
closure as if that would be the if the
purpose of getting closure
is what's behind it then sure it's up to
you if you if you have the mental
wherewithal to to handle that potential
landmine then sure but I mean especially
because of the substance abuse that this
just sounds like you're stepping into
yeah a swamp that's gonna suck you right
back you're stepping into a relapse is
what you're stepping uh but I mean if
you're seeking closure maybe but if
you're seeking to renew your
relationship nah I don't believe it no
because you're gonna neither do I but
some people do and it's real to them and
I've known people that really actually
makes a huge difference so if you're
like that then sure but but if you're
looking to reopen a potential
relationship which look I'm not telling
you what you're feeling and thinking you
know better than me because you're you
but it kind of sounds like that actually
might be what's behind it even if you
tell yourself otherwise what to see him
again and be with them yeah to be with
him even if you think you're seeking you
need closure but you're really good to
reconnect and I know it's hard two years
is a long time to be single especially
after a relationship that was super
intense both good and bad but I think
remains steadfast and know that there
will be someone some guy who comes along
that makes you stop thinking about that
guy yeah for sure that's I promise you
yeah I promise you that will happen and
in the meantime just work on yourself
stay sober and then talk to your
therapist who else do you talk to your
therapist about that for sure but yeah
who knows do you talk to about it
um
I mean I would talk about if you are
sober in those meetings you could talk
about it 100 and if you're not in
meetings and you and you are sober or
struggling just go to these meetings
yeah there's a lot on Zoom even if
you're still using go it's helpful I go
to some Zoom meetings I go to some that
are in like [__] they're all over the
world like uh because of Zoom like I go
in and I do my meetings
um sometimes
because usually meetings when the
in-person ones they're at like [__] 6
30 a.m at the beach or something and
you're just like I'm a comedian where do
you do that how do you I go I wake up
sometimes I'll do it at like 9 30. and
it'll be like a noon one a noon meeting
in Houston oh or like or literally I've
done them in uh like Scotland
like late at night I'll do I do do them
at 1am you could just bomb in you don't
know anybody yeah you can uh it's not
bombing I mean it's like it's open for
for anyone but like I I go in and I'm
sorry sorry I actually have a question
how do you get in
there's no there's like a forum oh we
just look and every hour on the hour
they show it and you're like okay I'm
gonna go to this meeting I'm gonna do it
at [__] midnight and it's in Scotland
or whatever oh and you go in yeah damn
sometimes I don't normally show my face
be a distraction you know what I mean
because I know that people that's it
says on the zoom it says crystally I'm
like I gotta [__] change your name I
did oh okay to skippity no I did I
changed it to theovan nice no but I um
yeah I I uh I do wanna I do want to go
to more ones in person
and then I do do that and then I don't
know man sometimes I feel like the Zoom
ones are are better although I do feel
like the Zoom ones you can do other [__]
like check your phone or [__] you
know look stuff up on the Internet while
you're on the thing you know that's not
ideal it's not ideal but yeah
yeah
so probably no is the answer should you
reach out to this guy but you're you so
you know I'm gonna do what you're gonna
do anyway probably yeah but but have
some faith in her you know talk to your
therapist and also do some of those
meetings
well be real with yourself if you want
to get back together this guy falling
Albania
and um I am here alone right now and I
was wondering if you had any tips on
just good ways to entertain yourself
when you're alone
I've considered going down the back okay
so what does this say
um this is a boring question right
yeah he called in a long time we did
really was this the guy the France guy
the France the guy with the girl the guy
with the girl and he was talking about
yeah he was thinking about going to
Frank following a girl to France yeah he
followed her to go to Albania dude
oh wow yeah this guy wait hold on okay
so what does it say here this is a
boring question what is the best way to
do a career
oh my God the best way to do a career
let me tell you something right now an
alien an absolute alien let me tell you
something right now anybody I'm gonna
straight up say it dude anybody who
travels alone is [__] nuts really
yeah
oh man I don't if you don't have that
thing
by the time you decide look at all the
things okay so I'm gonna go to Greece
alone okay okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go in November okay
I'm gonna get the flight today okay
okay
I get the flight
I get the thing maybe I'll
refund it I don't know but I get the
flight I get the insurance travel
insurance
if in
August September October November four
months
you don't think
ah [__] it I'm just gonna chill okay
you're a batshit crazy person wow that
is a heavy take I don't agree at all I
don't do that I don't like to travel
alone it's not Patrick really but when I
was younger
I really when you weren't all together
when you were younger sure but don't you
want to make a caveat then like it's
unless you're like a teenager early 20s
he's tall well that guy's absolutely
crazy we know that about him already
anyone who goes to another country to
find themselves is a [__] lunatic
that's not what he did you're right
there you didn't he didn't say I'm
looking for myself I know but I'm saying
you know he said here's the deal why
would you be solo traveling to just
Albania you're lonely no one likes you
and you're crazy sex tourism
nice
no but like when you let's just stick to
the question he's in Albania he said
he's in Albania dude wow I didn't know
look that nice I gotta go alone uh
what how do you what was the question
exactly how do you how do you how do you
have fun alone what do you do to have
fun alone dude what is this question
smack off you can do anything yeah you
can read about anything you have
anything you can go anywhere you want
cool to be alone it's cool to be alone
it's good to be alone sometimes but to
travel alone it hey congratulations
you're part of the Nutty Club
what if you really want to travel then
there's no one who wants to go you don't
go but what if you really want to oh it
sucks watch some more friends that want
to go no dude no it's just showboxers
bro this is a wrong take man that's fine
it's so Bonkers to travel alone and like
go backpacking by yourself like meet
people and have like real like things
Adventures yeah until it is cool and if
you do it you're nuts
it's not not cool
it's cool you're cool and nuts oh I see
okay so okay uh it's becoming a clearer
picture now you think about the person
at dinner and and you're all hanging out
y'all got jobs y'all [__] worked hard
you did your college [__] you you left
College you got married you had kids and
then there's one person that was like
dude
I went to Italy by myself for three
months and just chilled I would want to
talk to that guy because crazy people
are interesting but no but also because
he was in Italy for three months and
nobody at the table was they were all
just living their lives having kids or
doing their jobs that are boring I don't
want to hear about those guys that was
alone in Italy you also if there was an
assassin at the table you'd want to talk
about it talk to him absolutely because
he's [__] crazy no because he's an
assassin assassins are crazy I don't
want to just talk to a guy who's crazy
because he's crazy I I would beg to
differ because I do maybe yeah you're
crazy let's have lunch you know my
friends wow
uh you know my friends worst policy
yeah but you got less crazy crazy
friends now than you used to that is
true that is true
like you used to be friends with guys I
like wouldn't even want to let in my
house that is true or like know where I
live that is so true yeah now it's not
like that no I know that's so true I
wish oh man those those people were so
funny to [__] be around Jesus Christ
dude guess what
um what
two things okay one thing it's a
throwaway but the the reason why people
think that my legs are so skinny are not
because they're skinny but they're
because my knees are knobby and I'm
working on it okay don't quads are gonna
pop out okay so far we got one don't
care what else you got for me number two
that was the throwaway one this is the
real banger
dude I not can't I can't I actually
can't believe this
you know how I used to run the block on
cold water in Ventura
no but okay you know how I used to
[__] run the block I used to go okay
literally run the block okay yeah I knew
the guy who worked yeah yeah and there
was a [__] he did that coffee bean
okay but there was a [__] BG to go I
would go get the cops out it was the
best in the city yeah okay they all knew
me at the sushi place yeah and then the
[__] Western Bagel turned to Five
Guys yeah
I ran it I remember yeah okay but the
Coffee Bean was my [__] yes
I mean bro I was the mayor you know what
I mean right there in that little block
I was the mayor okay Governor [__]
not Governor but um mayor viragosa yeah
he [__] saw me once there I was there
okay but I'm just saying how crazy was
it to see a guy in the midst of a
re-election campaign he looked so dead
and tired right there was a camera crew
just getting up this like meet and greet
in a random place and he was just like
he got close to our faces when he shook
her hands and I was like wow it's a
misery to be a pilot but he did that for
me because he knows that I run that
little [__] he was basically trying
to get your endorsement right because if
I did that swayed like 18 votes right
and he won the old guy with the
briefcase with the Nesquik in it
remember him who always farted did he
would call the governor's office and
talk about all the Mexican Nationals
anymore you're so racist dude bro the
guy would come in with a [__] and
I've even told you the thing at the
Banger yet but the guy comes in with the
briefcase how old I hated Stephanie dude
I wanted to be that guy's friend oh I
hated that guy dude 70 allowed racist is
to farts all the time
nothing worse than he was terrible he
was terrible so hold on 70 right oh at
least would you say at least dude one
guy came in one time one guy came in a
black guy with like the
I don't even know what to call it
without sounding I'm ignorant but like
the the orange like
he was African you know dashiki maybe
maybe he had a did she
moved here maybe he had a Sudoku on I
don't know but so
maybe he had some chorizo on I have no
idea but he so the guy says when in Rome
and and he's oh my god oh oh oh wow
excuse me sir and he was like this is an
African guy oh [__] dude what are you
wearing all this for yeah it was it was
terrible
he was like sir you're ignorant and he
was like oh so he got into it good yeah
yeah I mean [__] this guy you know
um calling the governor's office he
would call him I think he was the mayor
honestly okay yeah he would say yeah I
want to talk to the mayor on his little
flip back then it was the you know about
all these Mexican Nationals yep and he
was right and he was right what are you
talking and he was right there are
Mexican Nationals B
you know the most racist you can be yeah
is to be loudly racist in public yeah
and seem like you don't care yeah yeah
yeah or you even notice 100 you know
um and so he so he uh
it's actually they talk about what's
inspiring it's inspiring that guy was so
racist and didn't give a [__] he was
just he was so off his [__] he was yeah
but he would come to the Coffee Bean
with a briefcase not like a backpack or
a duffel bag like a briefcase that you
like would see in a movie and like Dan
Aykroyd would have it you know and
you're like what it in 1980 you know and
in the briefcase he had some papers that
were uh something I guess yeah his cell
phone and
[__] Nestle Quick yep and he would go
order a Coffee iced coffee the powder
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then put
the thing in it and mix it up it was
actually hot coffee now that I remember
and it was so disgusting what a [__]
[__] and get on the horn talk to
[__] the mayor but
um anyway that coffee shop closed down
when oh it did 10 years ago okay maybe
not no probably like six years ago
it's been closed ever since
it's just there it's just there it's in
this building every time I drive by I'm
like
I loved it there I know that it sucked
dude oh God it sucked I can't even like
Express how much it sucked did you think
it sucked
um don't lie yeah don't lie I didn't
love it I mean it's a strip mall thank
you there's nothing the AC Vibe the AC
sucks it was the least of alive
dude the AC would just blast on you in
certain seats other places it was so hot
loved it Eddie Murphy would go there all
the time and he would always say what's
up he would always say hi to me yeah me
but me too and I was like you're a
comedian why is he saying he probably
didn't know which one was me you know
maybe or he thought I was your brother
yeah he was nice as [__] up yeah
anyway always with
cartoon comic book beautiful women
crazy yeah yeah but there's like
Rolls-Royce or Ben yeah running just
[__] there's one Eddie Murphy you
know yeah yeah and dude
uh
it's back it came back dude that's
yesterday
it's gonna be an Alfred's coffee oh yeah
baby you know I don't like Alfred's
coffee but I'm you you better believe
I'm gonna go dude you better go and not
only is it back dude you're back I'm
back
I'm gonna go in and be like I'm thinking
I'm back like dude this is the final
form of me not being canceled anymore is
that this [__] coffee shop is back
both of our producers just got up and
walked away from their seats
simultaneously and I can't see either
one of them anymore they're just gone
dude
I don't know I am so excited and I go no
way and I'm with Kristen dude I'm 43 in
this [__] I think about I have no way
dude look and she said oh my God and she
knows all about it the fact
that it's an Alfred means maybe I'll
actually come by yeah sometimes bro I'm
gonna go yeah you should oh it's heck
because it's actually going to be good
coffee oh it's hectic Coffee Bean and
Tea Leaf oh it's hectic which is a
nightmare oh it's hectic dude people
talk [__] about Starbucks drip coffee
Starbucks coffee is dead it's better
than Starbucks dirt water Starbucks is
[__] my it's my [__] it's really
squeezed it's so bad Coffee Bean is Bad
Coffee Bean's really bad but as well the
iced coffee of coffee bean is better way
better than the ice cream store well I
wouldn't know because I don't drink all
this coffee because I like actual coffee
okay I like actual but that's the
[__] [__] I get the espresso dude I
get it civil's good right civils cold
brew is very good
the espresso they make is is not good
and and I I went there and I said hey
because I always get the four shots over
ice damn okay that's exactly right so
don't come at me with the whole I only
drink real coffee bro I'm the man when I
get the four shots that doesn't mean
you're the man but all right well you
know what I'm saying though I'm really
gangster when it comes to my [__] so I
go to civil I get the four shots I
really want syllable to be civil to be a
good place I get the four shots it's not
it's not good so I say let me try the
cold brew that's what that's what I
always go back to if if the espresso
isn't gonna get the Cobra Cobra is
fantastic so I say the guy says four
shots I say now I get the Cobra this
time he says oh really how come I said I
like it better and he goes ouch
and I'm like he doesn't know I don't
like the foreshow also they're both made
by civils I know not him shut up dude I
don't like when I didn't like how he did
out but I really like that guy oh okay
well yeah uh really nice he's a good
with the bad all right should we do what
what yeah we can do another one but but
the Civil but the the the best one of
the change is Pete's
yeah I mean pizzas whatever but okay all
right dude what chain do you like Alfred
no I mean bigger change the Alfred's
there's like seven of them uh I guess of
the big chains Pizza is probably the one
that I I would count you out but there's
never one yeah those aren't around here
yeah I guess you're right you know yeah
yeah I guess you're right so Starbucks
cold water not cold water uh Coffee Bean
Starbucks Coffee Bean Pete's
those are the three that I know of that
are changing repeats that's the best of
those but there's that's because there's
the least Pete's it's always the ones
that don't have right but then you get
into the mom and pop shops that are
[__] terrible so I don't even want to
get started on that unless less terrible
than the CH the big chains though um
we're just going in circles all right
let's do one more all right let's do
another one
Matthew Modine oh yeah hey what's up
Delia Brothers we both love the show man
I listen every Sunday all right so guys
I was laid off this morning man that's
the first time it's ever happened to me
Blue Sky oh [__] that sucks I'm sorry so
the advice is I am asking is why do I
just go out and get another job
um full time
uh by trade I'm a draft spin I I uh got
a certification for that at tech school
um I design and draw 2D and 3D
construction documents and uh you know
so my advice is that I'm asking looking
for is do you guys think I should maybe
go back to school uh become an engineer
take this time to you know improve my
resume my level of Education
um or do I start my own business
freelance work for myself I I've been
doing it for 10 years I got plenty
experience you know both these things
would be hard a lot of money
um I've got a wife and two kids so it
would be tough it would be real tough
um so what would you guys do would you
take this time take it as a sign maybe
that life still rips uh and pursue
something better or the uh do you just
find another job get right back into it
working full time potentially getting
laid off again you know what would you
guys do thanks if there's an Avenue
towards having your own business and
working to yourself if that's a viable
Avenue that you can see daylight on yeah
do that yeah do that because more and
more
being an employee
it's going to just become more and more
precarious as time goes on that's not a
rule just throughout history always but
it is a rule to my eye right now being
an employee now anywhere is so
precarious
like bad it's just not a good deal for
in so many Industries I don't know about
yours but like see if you can
school is one Avenue that you look if by
the end of that school engineer school
there's like
money and jobs that will be available to
you right away that could be viable but
I think if there's a possibility of
having your own business and it seems
like it could actually work
go toward that full speed and I always
and you never know what's going to be
happening with like the [__] AI of it
all with the especially with your
profession like right I would just not
waste time trying to make your career uh
and you know I'm not going to schools
wasting time but like sometimes in some
cases it is but in his case it would be
after school he'd have a much more sort
of like he'd be able to actually get
work as an engineer I understand
and more what except for you don't know
what's going to happen with AI right but
I think that's a real thing if you start
your own business you could actually
fallen in some kind of whatever's going
on that's what that's what my point is
okay yeah yeah
uh all things said and done I feel like
if the Matt's right though you have to
see like an actual path towards it right
don't just blindly be like I'm gonna
start my own business that's what idiots
do they have I mean I'm not a big fan of
like the five year plan the 10-year plan
but have like a general idea of a
structure of a plan that's like okay
well first it's gonna be this it's going
to be hard until this and then if it is
if it does get better at this by this
time then I'm on to something and then I
can build on that and it's like have
benchmarks you know because otherwise
you'll feel like you're flailing and
you'll want to stop and quit and
you gotta have little benchmarks along
the way that make you remember that
you're on the path toward progress
but yeah start a business
I remember I'm not a businessman I'm a
business man right I mean definitely
don't forget that Jay-Z said that would
be really bad
Hove
do we know how Hova became his thing
yeah he called he started saying hey you
know what my thing is Hova call me Hova
what is Hova Jehovah Jehovah's Jehovah's
Witness he's a Jehovah's Witness no he's
Jesus he's like he's Jesus Christ that's
what he's saying yeah but all rappers
say that they do I'm like Jesus that is
that and came back
sacrilege [__] are they Christians
though
they all are they all Christians I don't
know if they're all Christians they say
that and they should be going they
should know that that sends them
straight to hell yeah they don't care
though nobody's really a Christian when
it comes down to it cool
but but I I know that that's not a
nickname he said tell me that asking is
where it comes from what is that
Jehovah's Jehovah Jesus okay that's very
weird but okay well it is weird is it
raining out it looked like it was gonna
rain when we when I was playing
[__] all that ah it's like come on mate
I was gonna get my car washed I guess
not listen guys Lifeline luxury there's
a new episode now so go to patreon.com
Lifeline luxury come on down Charlotte
and Little Rock Arkansas and Knoxville
and Nashville and Cleveland and
Pittsburgh and all these different
places uh chrislea.com I'll be there
soon and also uh leave a comment or oh
no no what the the if you want to call
in or whatever the hotline or the
sending the video we like the videos
better but the hotline works too you
want a one-on-one session with your with
with with Mr me
you go to mattelia.com book a session
with Mr me so save your life
and you want to merch go to life on
merch.com get every single piece of the
merchandise otherwise you're not a real
fan and that is upsetting to me and
and yeah and you get to send us pics
thank you and it's mostly that my knees
are knobby not the fact that I have
skinny legs so thank you very much guys
make sure you subscribed
[Music]